- So, to all of you,
"Barbie" has had many jobs,
as are represented in our audience today.
Lawyer, doctor, everything.
So what were all of your first paid jobs?
- (sighing) Oh, oh.
- Look, I'm gonna start
with the sigh, okay?
- I would say I was a
little league umpire.
- [Kelly] Oh.
(audience laughs)
- Shoulda checked the rules
before doing that gig,
'cause, man, ooh, those parents
on this side and on this side, what, what?
And I'm like, I don't, "Was
it a ball, was it a strike?
What is the difference?"
(all laughing)
And, "Can she be running now?"
"I don't know, she's out?
Is she out?
I don't know, I'm sorry," oh God.
- Oh my God, they just let anyone do it?
- Right.
- How did you get this job
if you didn't you know someone?
- No, I think I said I knew the rules,
and I did on some level.
They were there somewhere
and it didn't go so good.
I got fired, I was fired
from my umpire job.
- [Kelly] Well, like, shocking.
- Yep.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, they were like, "Find
someone that knows the rules."
You were an actor before
you were an actor.
You know how actors are always,
- Yes, always lying on your resume.
- [Kelly] Lying on your resume,
"I can totally ride a horse,
I'm totally an equestrian,
I'm totally this."
You were just ahead of your game.
America, what about you,
what was your first paid job?
- The first job I got paid to do,
that wasn't like an official job,
was my next door neighbor
had a very big pot belly pig,
and I got paid to clean up after the pig.
That's what I did.
- All right, making money
at a young age, I like it.
- I was a hustler, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I would take it where I could get it.
- [Kelly] Absolutely, what about you Issa?
- Similar, I had a neighbor
who needed her cats babysat.
That rhymes.
And I did that at like,
eight, but then I discovered
that I was allergic so I
had to quit the next day.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] I found out I was
allergic the hard way too.
I rescued one and I was
like, "What is happening?"
And I just couldn't,
- Yeah, broke out in the face.
- get it together, and we were like,
"We are highly allergic to cats."
So I was like, super,
- Devastated, I love cats.
- I found her a home.
- Me too, I love cats.
- But I can't mess with 'em.
- No more than dogs 'cause, I'm right.
But anyway,
(all laughing)
I'm just kidding, but not.
So what about you?
What was, like, your first paid job?
- I started, I was a hustler
too, I started young.
I was working in a restaurant.
I started when I was 10 working in, like,
the back in the kitchen.
But my hustle started earlier than that.
I used to actually, my
way of making money,
before I was working at a restaurant,
I would steal my brother's toys
and then sell them out on the street.
(Kelly gasps)
- I know, And he'd get
so mad, he'd be like,
"Where's my truck?"
- And I was like, "I got two bucks worth."
- Great!
- He was like, "Can I
have some of the money?"
I was like, "No, that wasn't
your store out on the street,
that was my store."
- So as a producer on this,
what do you hope people take away?
Like, the messaging?
- I think, I mean, first
of all, it's so fun.
I mean, when you see these
sets, it's like a dopamine hit.
Like, you just are so happy
and the movie is so funny.
It's also kind of unexpectedly
emotional, I have to say.
And it's weird,
I didn't think I would do a "Barbie" movie
and have so many conversations
about the meaning of life with,
you know, behind the scenes.
You know, like, 'cause
when we're talking about,
okay, "So life is perfect,
like if this is the utopia,
what's the perfect ending?
What's the version of what is happiness?
What is life?"
As all these questions came up
that we were trying to answer
so that we could kind of
round up this movie the way,
you know, it needed to be.
And it, you get, you end up having
these incredibly profound
conversations about life
and what's important, and what
makes really true happiness.
And that is all woven into the movie.
And there are quite, like,
you'll find moments where you're like,
"Wow, that really hit me in,
like a profound, emotional way."
And overall, it's just, it's
hysterical and it's funny.
It's a bunch of adults acting like,
having tantrums and being
children sometimes, so.
And it's a beautifully designed world.
It's just,
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
I think people are just
gonna really be happy
and have so much fun.
We had a whole miniatures workshop.
You could go, like,
that hand paint tiny flamingos like this,
that then I'd go on set,
and there'd be a flamingo
mailbox that life-size.
I mean, everything was, you know,
the painted backdrops,
the dream houses that we
were actually, you know,
going down the slide to the
pool and all that stuff.
There was so much,
in-camera, kind of trickery,
which is very satisfying
and it gives you that tangible feel.
Like Greta said from the start she's like,
- Yeah it feels like you
just jumped into the world.
- you sorta feel like they can
reach in and grab everything
'cause that's would of play
with Barbies and stuff,
so, it's really beautifully crafted.